[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm cabby HD here and
this this is the one plus 3t and there's
just a couple things you need to know
about this phone obviously it looks very
familiar to the phone 1 plus released
less than six months ago the one plus
three one of the best budget phones out
there for the record great phone for
under 400 bucks highly recommended so
the one plus three T is - the one plus
three as the iPhone 6s was - the iPhone
6 basically T is the new S it's kind of
an iteration Allah the phone that came
out back in June it's a spec bump fit
into the exact same design you wouldn't
know it was new just by looking at it
unless you knew exactly what you're
looking for so here we go I'll tell you
exactly what's new number one is you
might have noticed is the slightly new
color this is called gunmetal and you
can see it versus a one plus three is
silver you notice the difference right
it's subtle it's slightly darker it's
kind of more like a Space Gray type of
thing I like it
there's also a soft gold as well number
two is it has a Snapdragon 820 one
inside at the higher 2.35 gigahertz
clock speeds so not under clocked like
it is in the pixel so this is a slightly
newer super high-end chip and when you
pair that back with the same six
gigabytes of RAM you have yourself a
pretty high I mean one of the highest
end spec sheets of any smartphone so
number three and I think that this is my
favorite is they fit a much larger
battery in this phone in the exact same
dimensions this one + 3 T is rocking a
3400 milliamp hour battery up from the
3000 milliamp hour battery you had
before that is legit I've been preaching
about you know if you can make a phone
battery as big as possible even if the
phone's a little bit thicker you should
do it so now you're getting a 13% bigger
battery with the 3 T in the same metal
body that should be nice that should
translate to much better battery life
and screen on time number 4 is this is
also now a 128 gigabyte phone so double
the storage you had with one plus three
was a 64 gigabyte phone tops so 100 when
ta that should alleviate some of the
concerns of people who really wanted
expandable storage you still don't get
that but I keep my entire spotify
library downloaded for flights and
twenty eight gigs was great for me
number five is the cameras so the one
plus 3t has the exact same 16 megapixel
camera on the back that's no change
still pretty damn good but it's now
rocking a new 16 megapixel front-facing
camera so a big upgrade from the 8
megapixel selfie camera from the oneplus
3
obviously you're only going to care
about this if you take a lot of selfies
or front-facing video but for what it's
worth I did notice a difference in the
quality of the photos and the videos
from the front-facing camera
it did seem to struggle a little bit
with focus sometimes possibly since it's
also an F 2.0 aperture but when you do
now focus with this front-facing camera
you can tell the difference and the
selfies look really good from the 1 + 3
T nice and wide-angle decent colors
decent dynamic range again and better
sharpness and even a slightly shallower
depth of field when your subject is
closed and finally number 6 last but not
least is the software so you note out of
the box the 3t is running Android
marshmallow still but with their
upgraded very light oxygen OS and that
should be upgraded to Android new get
very soon and retaining all these
features alongside the 1 plus 3 so the 1
plus 3 isn't becoming obsolete that
would just be nuts in half a year
they're still giving that a software
upgrade as well but obviously the higher
spec version this 3t replaces the 3 and
has a couple new looks and features in
oxygen OS as well so they're going to be
selling this 3t for 439 so again still
really high-end flagship specs for a
relatively low price like the pixel with
the same chip with a lower clock speed
is what 650 bucks to start the galaxy s7
600 bucks you've looked at all the
numbers on paper and in user experience
this is a great phone for another pretty
low price all the rest of the things I
didn't talk about in this video are
still exactly the same from the oneplus
3 review I'll link it below if you want
to watch it again but it's the same
great 1080p display same great size and
metal build and form factor decent
speakers it's still the fastest charging
phone in the world I'm pretty sure right
now so - charging is awesome to have so
all those things plus the upgrades and
about a $40 price hike for six months
later that's pretty good in my opinion
I'm liking this it kind of seems like
oneplus is picking up sort of where
Nexus left off before pixel showed up
where people were really excited for a
really mid-range to high-end phone that
had really lightweight or pier
stock Android for a really low price and
the experience would be awesome
well now pixels like 650 bucks so if you
still want a lightweight Android
experience for around half that price
400 bucks ish then seems like one plus
three T is the way to go you know how I
said the one plus three T is to the
three as the 6s is to the six well turns
out oneplus did this on purpose they did
it for the exact reason the letter T
comes one after s so like one better
than s kind of one upping Apple in that
way whatever maybe they're trolling but
well played one plus three T gets my
thumbs up in my nod of approval and it
will probably be right up at the top
like the highest end budget smartphones
you can get the smartphone Awards 2016
is coming up if you haven't already
noticed so that's something that we're
thinking a lot about either way that's
been it people said that one plus three
owners should be mad because the phone
is obsolete six months later no it's not
that's still also one of the best budget
smartphones of the whole year but that's
pretty much all I have to say about the
three T let me know what you guys think
in the comments section below thank you
for watching and talk to you guys the
next one peace
[Music]